First, congratulations on making it through the course.
You have learned so much.
You've learned how to calculate the circumference of the earth.
How to quantify motion. >>How to use Newton's laws to calculate acceleration.
How to keep The Netherlands dry. >>How to find your location at sea.
How to protect tall buildings from lightening.
And even a bit of special relativity.
Now, it's time to use what you've learned and put it in practice on the final exam.
This exam will have no deadline, and you can take it whenever you want.
You'll get instant feedback on each question,
so you can submit as many answers as you'd like without penalty.
Once you're finished with the exam, you can complete the course
by going to your transcript page and clicking on the "Complete Course" button.
You will get one of four certificates based on how many answers you get correct.
The criteria for each of these certificates is below the video.
Good luck on the exam.
Teaching this course has been an incredible experience.
I've been really blown away by the amount of curiosity and helpfulness
that I've seen in the forums.
I'd like to say thank you to Jonathon for everything he's done to make this class possible,
to Grant, the editor and videographer.
Without him this wouldn't have happened.
And, of course, to you for everything you've done to make this class such a success.
I can't wait to see you in future Udacity classes. Good luck on the exam.